hi my name is Todd gaily and the title
of my talk is the Wolfen language in a
sailboat racing telemetry system I'll be
talking about a system I'm creating to
help me race and cruise my sailboat
touring machine I use a whole host of
different technologies to help me
analyze display record various sailing
data to help me make better decisions on
the race course and for later analysis
at home I'd like to talk today about a
system I'm building using a whole suite
of wolfram technologies for my sailboat
Turing machine to help me get the most
out of her whether I'm racing or
cruising the Turing machine is a new
wallet I bought her just the spring I've
raced on other people's boats on Lake
Michigan for years I finally decided
it's time to get my own boat and
campaign her the way I think it should
be done one of the factors in this
decision was that I knew I could use
Wolfram language at Wolfram system to
create the system like the one I'm
describing today to really give me give
me an edge out on the race course
because I think there's a lot of things
that are that I know can be done on a
boat that I don't see people doing and
and I want to I want to see what uh what
can be done with that so real quickly
there's touring machine
she's a Catalina 27 2015 2 make a
credible racer it's got a great big
cockpit holds a lot of crew which is
very comfortable inside sleeps 4 has a
bathroom and everything so it's very
comfortable boat for all sorts of things
and it's also very well set up for
single heading which is something that I
do a lot now a short little video just
to get you in the field not very
exciting it's very very short I just
want to put you out on the water for a
moment in in Turing machine
so anyway there's so this is a starting
line just over the starting line see I
raced just off of the downtown Chicago
this is flying along with the spinnaker
my intrepid crew oh you know I was going
to turn up the volume here
we caught that guy so anyway all right
so there's a little down leaning up with
saline Turing machine
all right now is this sake people see
this it's always one all right so these
are the system components here in the
upper left I mean there's a built in the
instrument display on the boat that's
not really part of my system but of
course there is one but the boat
instruments
I have wind speed wind direction the
speed of the boat through the water the
compass heading the water depth which
I'm not making much use of at the moment
and GPS position in the cockpit I have
an Android tablet with some custom
software that I'm writing to display
various controls and information the way
I want them displayed that's the heart
of the visual user interface part of the
system I have an Amazon echo tap in the
cockpit that's it sitting there this is
for the voice interface which we'll see
a little bit later on in the cabin
there's a laptop PC this is the hub the
the core of the system it's running
mathematic of course and it does really
all the work it's plugged into the boat
network captures data from the Vote
network from the instruments does
various logging and analysis of the data
and it also communicates with the tablet
in the cockpit and then I have an iPhone
in the cabin as well that's just a Wi-Fi
hotspot the only thing that in the
system that needs internet is the voice
interface the Animas on reco needs to
talk to the internet it's important
because it is the one that the system
doesn't rely on the internet because
there's places that I say where I can't
get a phone signal I can't do it but I
can't get a Wi-Fi all right so
so what's my motivation for creating a
system well for one thing I mean
basically racing is hard there's a
tremendous amount of things to
concentrate on and think about while
you're out there in the racecourse it's
hard to even appreciate that you sail
around you think this is easy
get on the racecourse where are you
trying to say absolutely as fast as you
possibly can at every moment it's really
quite challenging
I often race short-handed the small crew
some members my crew inexperienced I
really need whatever assistance I can
get in terms of strategic ideas or
information about how fast the boat is
sailing and how fast I should be sailing
there's a lot of folklore in sailing
it's amazing how much folklore there
isn't sailing and I really wanted to get
some actual data analysis in to really
try to understand what's going on now I
know there's there are commercial
hardware and software that solves some
of these problems they're expensive
you know chart plotters and other types
of minister route displays and there's
racing software that does some of the
things that that this offer will be able
to do in terms of what it can display
and with what it can tell you about your
boat
but this stuff is very expensive and
there's no way it's going to do what I
actually wanted to do it there's no way
it's gonna be flexible enough I know
that using the advantage of wolfram
technologies that I can easily put
together something I mean the Android
programming for the laptop for the
tablet is challenging but the actual
core analysis and collection and soft
you know that is all done in Wolfram
language that's actually relatively
straightforward so like I know that I
can tweak this exactly the way I want it
alright so here's some of the Wolfram
technologies I use the device framework
device open device to read that's for
acquiring data from the Vote network I
have some cables that plug right into
the laptop and it runs an hour you
schedule tasks very powerful feature of
Mathematica that you can run things in
the background that don't interfere with
the normal use of the
of Mathematica on the computer so I have
several times a second I have scheduled
tasks that are sampling the boat Network
collecting this data socket listen I use
socket listened created essentially a
micro web server on the PC the PC has
its own hosted network Wi-Fi network
socket listen and really the code I use
for socket listen is comes right out of
an example that's in the docs
it's just sits there listening on a
socket waiting for requests coming in
the requests come from the tablet the
tablet is constantly pinging the laptop
to get the latest data and display it
and and then I have this background
scheduled tasks that are constantly
collecting data and updating this state
structure for the voice interface I use
the Alexa package
she's going to be waking up every time I
say your name this package I want to
remind you that's freely available if
you want to use I highly recommend that
you get it just like pack that update
Alexa in your Mathematica session and
then type Alexa in the documentation
Center to go into the docs and then two
for one here the Wolfram cloud hosts the
Alexa scale for the voice interface like
I said I could use the cloud more but I
have to really be internet free as much
as possible out on the boat and and then
of course I have the full suite of
analysis and visualization functions in
Mathematica for during and after the
race all right so I just want to give an
example this sort of thing that we can
learn from to use on the course I mean
this is a little manipulate that talks a
bit is a representation of both speaking
tacking upwind now you probably know
they're both said well can't sail
directly into the wind
those sailboats can sail at most around
45 degrees pointing into the wind so
here we have two boats the wind is the
black arrow in that little orange flag
up there is the mark Biltz are sailing
two just to make things easy I've got
the boat starting on different tacks
directions so the red boat is going to
tack once it's going to sail all the way
out to the side and tap once towards the
mark and the green boat tacks randomly
now of course you would never actually
tandem Lyanna race and you would also
never sail tack just one sail all the
way out to the ley line and up to the
mark for reasons that are beyond the
scope of this talk but I just want to
compare what happens to these two boats
you probably know as they go up the
course it doesn't really matter how many
times you tack they tie boats will
always tie now in the real world every
time you throw an attack you slow down
so you're not going to tack a lot but to
a first approximation you you it doesn't
really matter however that is not the
case when there's wind shifts so now
I've modified this scenario to show but
the red boat is going to tack on wind
shifts when it detects that the wind has
shifted it's against it it will tack the
green boat will continue to tack
randomly so let's just run it for a
moment here now you notice the wind is
coming five degrees from the left here
so the red boat is lifted it's its own
advantageous tack and the green boat is
on the disadvantage is tacking he's not
smart enough to know that I didn't
tackle way so what I'm not going to ship
the wind back to the other side of the
course and then maybe back again and we
see that the red boat is now way ahead
and if you notice the course of the red
boat he's really always doing better
than 45 degrees he's he's you know in
phase with the wind shifts and so he's
taking a much straighter course to the
mark the green bow here is in here can
see in several places it's going more
sideways than forward so this just shows
you how important it is the number one
thing on the upwind leg is to recognize
wind shifts
so so the question should I tack is
definitely not easy to answer on the
racecourse you want to know how big is
the wind shift is this a persistent
shifter is that only momentary you know
is it worth the speed loss that I'll
incur by tacking in fact to tack back
because I mean I made a mistake that's
to tax and then you also want to know is
there an overall pattern of oscillating
wind today or is it stable so anyway
these are questions that can easily be
answered by a system that's monitoring
the wind direction during the grace okay
another thing I want to talk about and
this is more of an example of sort of
after the fact data analysis it's
something called a polar diagram a polar
diagram is a representation of the
expected performance of a sailboat in
every direction relative to the wind
it's different for every boat every boat
has different performance
characteristics and also for the same
boat it's different for every different
set of sails and every different wind
speed you can get polar diagonals for
your boat but they're generally produced
from theoretical considerations which
really means this sort of they're really
not worth very much it's just guessing
based on similar boats but I want to get
the only way to really know how your
boat performs is to go out and measure
it and of course I have the capability
collecting data constantly so here is an
example of a polar diagram just in
general what this is showing is that
this the the wind is coming from the top
of the diagram this line represents the
the speed of the boat going in that
direction you see this diagram this
picture shows various both going in
various directions so so this boat here
in the upper right is going relatively
upwind and this point here show us how
fast is going it looks like maybe a
little more it's a circular scale here a
little more than four knots right this
boat here is going almost dead downwind
it's doing a little less than four knots
so this is what a pole diamond looks
like and they generally always have this
kind of lobe heart shape and way you can
use this is
if you just draw a straight line
perpendicular to the wind direction and
just lower until it just touches the top
of the curve and mark those two points
those two blue dotted lines show the
optimum angle for sailing upwind you
notice how this curve sort of tails away
this way as the boat starts to point
higher higher into the wind it slows
down and it stopped the curve ends here
because the boat couldn't even sail this
direction it would just come to a stop
so anyway these points show you and you
can see for this picture it's around 45
degrees off to wind that that's how you
can tell exactly how high you can point
and maximize your up wind velocity made
good so here is my polar diagram for
Turing machine this was about 10 knots
of wind with this the jib in main and
you know the date has been called
there's a lot of junk that has to be
pulled out but that's relatively
straightforward you know what's the
number one thing you notice when you
look at this diagram which is that it's
has the right shape but it's not
symmetric right did one starboard tack
when we're heading in this direction
joining machine is considerably faster
than on port tack so I was I mean this
confirms something we've noticed is that
you can tell the boat is not as fast on
port as on starboard tack but this put
some real data to it now that's
something I'll have to look at in the
off season sometimes there's various
reasons that might be maybe this mast
isn't exactly straight or the rig isn't
tuned properly sometimes the keel isn't
put on exactly straight but these are
all things to look into but any case if
you if you to draw that horizontal line
across the here across the top here see
where it touches it looks like about
here and here so this is actually very
good because that's much higher than 45
that's around 40 I would say so that
means touring machine points into the
wind very well probably around 40
degrees away from the wind which is
that's a good sign all right and here's
another program for more complicated one
this is not from touring machine this
shows two different you know each of
these curves this there's two of them
you see there's this one and then kind
of breaks and then as a second one
that's because this top curve is for the
jib
and the bottom curve is when flying a
spinnaker I just the point I want to
make about about this is that it's to
know the optimum angle to sail upwind on
a boat is generally very easy if you
point teeny bit too high sail start to
luff boat slows down you know you're
doing it wrong but when you're going
downwind it's very it's much more
difficult lots of people don't realize
that the boat sails relatively slowly
dead downwind it's not a good direction
to sail you almost never sail directly
downwind and you can see that on these
curves say let's take a look at this the
inner curve right you can see the dead
downwind this boat only sails around
three knots about out here at 150 or 130
days boat is sailing almost five knots
so when you're out there on the course
you know if I sail dead downwind I mean
this is assuming my course is dead
downwind as it often is in a race you
know you're going slow but if you go
over here you'll speed up but it's not
obvious whether you're not going right
to the course so it's not obvious where
the correct point is to go to sort of
maximize your speed towards the mark
anyway that's what the polar diagram
shows once again these little dots show
the optimum direction to sail to go
downwind get the greatest velocity made
good downwind and again you can you can
these plants are just if you imagine a
horizontal line drawn across here that's
where it would touch every time so here
so this is for eight knots of wind this
curve you can see the boat needs to sail
around 145 or 143 or something like that
degrees off the wind so this is a really
useful picture to get and here's the
data for Turing machine once again it's
faster under starboard tack there's
something you have to deal with but but
already I've learned something very
useful to know which is this point about
here this is around 160 so it means with
the wind around I mean this is around
140 the wind around 40 degrees off
stern is the fastest place to sail when
you're trying to get downwind at least
on starboard tack I have to get more
data really on port tack to understand
that so already I've learned something
that I did not know it was not at all
obvious just from sailing around that
140 at least in 10 knots of wind is the
right angle to go at okay now I don't
really have time to talk about seizing
the mutation stuff I just want to get on
to the very simple system demo sort of
God here this is actually I don't want
to try to project the android screen so
I'm going to run in an emulator
now I want to say that the system is
really just getting started in
particular this Android program isn't
just a toy it's very long way to go but
it is functioning and I do want to show
it so what's happening here is that
there's several moving parts here I have
the PC down here below me this is of
course it's not capturing data from the
boat it's playing back recorded data and
it's playing back recorded data at a
very high speed
so there's numbers are flying by it's
much faster than it gets collected but I
wanted to play it fast enough so you
could see things happening on on the
screen so this PC is playing back
recorded data projecting it over the
network this is an emulated Android
program just like runs on the tablet in
the cockpit it's displaying that both
speed and the true wind and apparent
wind speeds now this dial is the wind
indicator the large gray dial is the
apparent wind the small blue dial is the
true wind that's not even hooked up so
it just sits there stuck at zero but
you'll also notice that every now and
then that meter will swing to the other
side when I was recording this data I
was sailing attacked me back and forth
so you see that things swing it swings
the wrong way it swings all the way
around the long way if you watch it
that's it I have to fix that it's an
issue with the speedometer code that I
started working from that was sort of
designed for a different type of
speedometer there's like a branch cut at
the top and I'm gonna have to figure out
how to get around that but in any case
that's actual what you see it goes the
wrong way as we just we just tacked in
it it's fun the wrong way so now we're
on starboard tack so this is actually a
real demo the only thing that's you know
the all the networks in use are exactly
what's happening on the boat except for
the and I just want to show real quickly
I do have a voice interface and cannot
imagine how useful it is to have a voice
interface in the boat because sometimes
you're saying you've got one hand on the
tiller in one hand on the mainsheet it's
incredibly useful to not have to get up
and touch something or
even this Android is hanging around my
neck I still have to use my hands on it
it's incredibly valuable so I can talk
to it right now I can say Alexa asked
the boat what is the true wind speed
come on Alexa ask the boat what is the
true wind speed so that's actually
picking from these numbers it's exactly
like it would actually be happening on
the boat you can say Alexa should I tap
sorry
Alexa ask the boat if I should tack
Alexa asked the boat if I should tack
you can also feel me like Alexa asked
the boat how am i sailing right now that
was fake because he's not I don't
actually
she actually answered she told me how
fast I should be sailing and that's
extremely valuable to know and I get
yeah once this information of these
polar diagrams is recorded in the system
then I can actually know how fast they
should be sailing at any moment and I
can just ask and being able to do that
that one question how am i sailing is an
incredibly valuable thing out there what
you're trying to avoid crashing into
other boats steering requires continuous
concentration it's really really very
valuable
alright so real quickly
final fly here so some of the questions
that the system could answer including
through a voice interface you know how
far to the next mark what's the bearing
to the next mark lots of times it's hard
to actually the dimeric marks are very
small in the water you don't actually
know which direction it is how long till
I reach the next mark how fast my
sailing you know am I on the optimum
angle to the wind at the moment how far
away's the ley line even very technical
things like should I do a job set or a
bear away set at the next mark you know
what sail should I use on the next leg
that we may have shifted and the system
will tell me you should set the
spinnaker for the next leg and I
wouldn't have known that if I didn't
have the system so in any case these are
just some of the things that kept this
this will be able to tell me and
actually even through a voice interface
okay that's all I have thank you very
much
[Applause]